it might be hard to imagine anybody
besides Margot Robbie as Barbie even
though there were originally other
actors attached to the long-awaited
Barbie movie still according to a new
article in time Robbie wouldn't have
taken the movie if she was the only one
playing Barbie hi Barbie hi Barbie hi
Barbie hi Barbie hi Barbie hi Barbie hi
Barbie hi Barbie as the piece explains
Robbie's Barbie definitely is the
traditional version of the character
people remember blonde blonde hair long
tan legs pink outfits the works but
after Mattel introduced a much wider
variety of Barbies into its roster it
made it possible for the movie to depict
the world's most famous doll in many new
ways in fact Robbie revealed that
without other Barbies she wouldn't have
been interested in the role saying if
Mattel hadn't made that change to have a
multiplicity of Barbies I don't think I
would have wanted to attempt to make a
Barbie film